[Music]
do we know that it's airborne and it can
spread just by standing next to somebody
who is speaking and not only a question
on pete davidson so hard he transitioned
[Laughter]
dude we gotta be [ __ ] the monkey pox
bro we're gonna keep an eye on that dude
let's see now here's the problem hi i'm
pete davidson you might know me as the
funniest guy in the history of snl well
it's funny it's funny you say that
because now i have to do that i was
going to do this story a little later
but now i have to segue to it because of
my autism you know who does a really
good pete davidson robbie goodwin oh
robbie goodwin is ripped
i mean he does a lot of good voices but
his pete davidson is so full it's so
full of spikes
so
save me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
kanye west is never shy about his
feelings especially when it comes to his
estranged wife kim kardashian's former
beau p davis to be fair right and from
day one i've always had the same take on
this kanye you married and impregnated a
succubus
somebody who is already very widely
known and identified as a succubus it's
not even like you couldn't see it coming
it's not like kim kardashian was like
this obscure person and you just got
caught in a bad situation here i mean
she was like on paper known as the
succubus i thought it was a matter of
record yeah and you made her the mother
of your kids so that's a really good
point you know all this [ __ ] is your own
[ __ ] doing don't get me wrong pete
davidson's horrible but listen to this
but the mother of your kids the woman
you married is just the kind of woman
who would have [ __ ] pete davidson you
should have known better
and in the wake of keith's split a
source tells e.t pete's been in therapy
for years but now he's taking it a step
further pete is seeking trauma therapy
help in large part due to kanye's
constant threats and public attacks by
the way pause trauma therapy trauma
therapy this is just so not that he
needs to help because every we already
showed like every woman wants to [ __ ]
this guy now that's the sympathy when
you become when you're pete davidson and
you get a couple broads under your belt
other women now want to [ __ ] you just
because how many other women you [ __ ]
one because when you spiral over every
woman women like to like women are like
i want to make pete davidson spiral too
exactly also can i just say something
hey when you write e.t source you can
just say dave cyrus we all it's fine
what
am i wrong
i don't know for a fact look dave cyrus
has just taken on the role of pete
davidson's publicist now
does he really oh my god dude he talks
about pete when he talks about himself
does he really yes
that's sad i like dave
um
it's in his mother's basement where he
lives
which is a true thing that's not me
making fun of him no i know he lives
with his mom yeah you know pete davidson
[ __ ]
what's funny to me too is like i gotta
go to trauma derp because all these
threats from kanye and it's like no it's
a very public thing and this is what
rappers do like
like if honestly that's a good point
you're dating a rapper's ex what do you
think's gonna happen if i was [ __ ]
like uh
you know if i was [ __ ] like uh you
know
j if jay-z and beyonce broke up and i
started [ __ ] beyonce
maybe right yeah i think you can look by
the way her new song is actually kind of
fire okay you don't have to [ __ ] simp
for her immediately they're still
together no just the one song okay um
but let's say i start [ __ ] beyonce
which like he said is possible it's very
possible he's gotta lose like another 15
more pounds uh
but
i would be if anything couldn't [ __ ]
kelly rowland so just relax guys
you're right no actually probably she's
the hotter one she just has to she just
has to get the day off at [ __ ] you
know whatever restaurant she works at
now
the hungry crab
it's freaking she just has to she just
has to uh get out to get a shift off
from jimmy's uh
was it jimmy's seafood
um
no but like i would be if i start
[ __ ] beyonce i would be when just say
when when i start [ __ ] beyonce i
would be
more pissed if jay-z didn't make a song
where he's wrapping me in a body bag and
throwing me off a cliff right
like
he's like oh i'm in trauma therapy
because i got threatened by you know
jay-z is kind of a [ __ ] so no i get it
but i'm just saying if you weren't
writing a song about how you want to
beat my ass and claymation throwing me
off a cliff i'd be more insulted that
i'm like wait so i'm not even like he he
doesn't even view me as a threat
you know what it's not even that it's
not even like kanye was making fun of
him and pete david's this trauma stuff
that's [ __ ] because pete davidson
was going on weekend update and like
addressing it you know it's not like he
was just going back and forth with him
the entire time right they were taking
pot shots at each other and now pete
that's the thing with p right p wants to
make fun of everybody p wants to be the
snarky guy in the room but he also wants
to be the sensitive boy and it's like
you can't be both right
like you can't be both
violet music video it's kanye's track
with the game called easy and when it
first dropped in march pete reportedly
reached out to yay to settle the beef
since deleted screenshots of the alleged
convo between the two circulated online
wait who released the screenshots
in bed with your wife
oh my god
wait a second
pete leaked them
because by the color you could tell by
the color of who's sending the message
and who's receiving it p tweeted it in
bed with your wife yeah and yours
talking about trauma no no you're
taunting him and i'm not gonna know that
i'm kanye but i remember when this came
out in the news they were covering this
we covered this that he was like
doing this kind of [ __ ] and it's like
okay then
you know what i mean like i'm sorry but
like
if i'm doing that if i'm [ __ ] all
right now now we're switching to kanye
again uh when i'm [ __ ] kim kardashian
you're pregnant no but like
if if you start doing [ __ ] like this i
don't care if somebody's famous i don't
care if they're not famous i don't care
if they're white black gay or straight
like
you're cruising for a [ __ ] ass
whooping right like yeah i don't condone
violence over any words this is not the
kind of guy i am but i can understand
some situations sometimes so like if
somebody was like if i'm like wow you
just lost your cool like that and beat
his ass like what's wrong with you and
you go yeah because he was texting me
pictures of him in bed with my ex-wife
mother of my kids and he's bragging like
yeah i whoop that ass and i'd be like
you know it looks like he was kind of
begging for you to whoop his ass you
kind of deserve you kind of deserved it
right you deserved it right yeah exactly
but that's not words though that's
actions you you you [ __ ] with some
extra steps you know what i mean you
didn't just say some [ __ ] oh i'm in bed
you sent a [ __ ] selfie yeah you
deserve to have your [ __ ] ass whooped
yeah that that is a fight that like
you know what i mean that's one of those
fights even if you're my best friend and
you did that i'd have to sit out that
fight i'd be like look man
i can't defend you right now you have to
take that ass weapon
pete asking kanye to calm down while
praising kim for being a great children
[ __ ] you guys are literal children
this is so gay mother he's just super
genuine and he's just super genuine
that's a that's a compliment you come up
for with people that don't have any good
qualities yeah kim well she made it
clear on her hulu docu series the
kardashian oh good
questions she doesn't agree with how
kanye handles his feeling honey your
your left titty is popping out the side
they're so big
you see that yeah stop trying to [ __ ]
squeeze them things out yeah let them
breathe girl
like all i can do is control how i react
to something i can't control how he
treats me
and yeah you can
yeah you can because if you're being a
[ __ ] all the time the dude's gonna get
more angry at you you have you're in a
lot of control women always go like i
have no control yeah the [ __ ] you do
quit being a [ __ ] you [ __ ] how about
this i've shown you how to turn the tv
on 40 times why do i need to go turn it
on
since news broke that keat is done so
after nine months of dating the rapper
reacted to the split online sharing a
fake cover of the new york times with
the fake headline that read skeet
davidson dead at age 28. it has since
been deleted from his instagram
and aside from the socials
it's e.t
social media a source tells eta is way
happier with pete out the picture quote
he never took their relationship
seriously or felt good about pete being
around that's also
dave cyrus
he's also friends
dave e.t source cyrus yeah i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
as for how pete's been handling the
breakdown
another source and that was my that [ __ ]
kills me every time can you tell by my
face and he just deadpans the camera
wake up another source tells e.t pete is
bummed things didn't work out with kim
but he is focused on the future in terms
of his career and personal life what
what future you got no girl you got no
snl now so what are you doing
i think he's really banking on being a
big speaker he's gonna get like two
movies one will be a judd apatow one the
other one will be one done by laura
michaels and then after that pete's
gonna
probably throw a sitcom to him about
like some staten island staten island
loser or something that'll last for
maybe two seasons maybe two after that's
canceled you're going to see pete
davidson
find a committee making appearances in
that he's going to probably settle into
some cushy gig like hosting some sort of
american idol but for wiggers or
something i mean that's the trajectory
of something like him pete david said
normally somebody that's going to be
around forever like norm mcdonald pete
davidson's are going to burn out i
normally would agree with you but
there's something about him that they
just are put they won't stop pushing him
somebody wants pete davidson to be a
thing
and they're not letting it go i guess
you're right
in fact he's been busy working in
australia
bro i'm telling you that's the thing
he's the same thing it's the same person
as hillary clinton
he's somebody that they want to make
everyone like they everyone they want to
make her into something or him into
something and nobody wants them to be a
thing
in fact i sent you a pete davidson
related short to on facebook when you uh
when you get a chance of when we're
ready to
put a a exclamation point on the uh on
this [ __ ] segment
did you hear about this
so katy perry was on tick tock or
whatever and she was doing one of those
stupid filters that like
you know picks random things for you
and it like shows your
w at all you know what house will you
have when you're you know older and who
will you marry and all those kind of
things watch this she actually had to
apologize for this because that like
this actually was being talked about a
lot just from this tick tock video
all right here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
and guess what hold on guess what i
found this the other day and in this
moment
i love katy perry again yeah she's had
quite a fall from grace but she she
wasn't even throwing a hair back guys
she's like a lesbian anymore she won she
she won me back over with this video
[Music]
do you not immediately love her now
again yeah like what's the i mean why'd
she apologize that's it that's a funny
joke
because everyone started covering it and
you know these look a lot of these
entertainment blogs now are just
basically [ __ ] stir
like they just stir [ __ ] so a bunch of
blogs wrote about it and then like the
entertainment people picked up on it and
then she was like oh i'm so i'm just
trying to make a joke
the pete davidson thing is is funny to
me because ever ever since ever since he
um
came out
and said you know louis ck was mean to
him remember we covered that a couple
years ago and
one couple things i learned when we did
that because that's one of the earlier
stuff that we clipped there's a lot of
pete davidson fans
um and i don't know who they are but
there are probably also brendan schwab
yeah i would argue that i bet you that's
probably a good crossover brandon said
they're friends
um so uh yeah i used my boy um i told
him you'll go kill it in snl pete
davidson bro that guy's a [ __ ] killer
bro [ __ ] he's got a huge dick
he's got big piece we're gonna talk
about his penis but uh but but ever ever
since like
that when he was like louis ck was mean
to me i was like all right man you know
what you're a [ __ ] loser i i don't
even want to hear it he
he he's a whiny baby
he
pete davidson everybody has for has had
her has had a friend like pete davidson
some [ __ ] dude who looks like a
junkie who probably was a [ __ ] junkie
uh no offense virgie and um i never took
them to high school you find out years
later every chick in your high school
[ __ ] well [ __ ] him and they want to
fix him but he's still a [ __ ] loser
to this day
and he just he's the one that made it
he's the one out of a million of guys
like that that made it you know that's
um you know he's one of those guys whose
girlfriends are constantly saying well
what happened at that job you had at the
car wash yeah man i had to get up really
early for that you know it's like
and i'm still trying to like you know
you know honey i'm up at night i'm like
training for this esports thing did you
get me more cigarettes by the way i'm
cigarettes i'm training right now
i'm training for this halo tournament